How did you get involved with the dreadnought
boy scheme. Well i'd always wanted to
to either go to sea or immigrate.
First of all i tried to join the
but much marine and things were
very bad in around that time
in the middle twenties i couldn't
get get on anything like that. I
tried to go to canada and they told me
that i was too old that they wanted boys
people in sixteen and seventeen and i was
almost eighteen. So i was determined to
do something and i went to
the immigration officers of
australia house i can't remember where
i was in new castle. Where i lived and
i fell in papers for to
go to australia. I was
i think eighteen by then
and of course i was
a man and i didn't need parent
permission. So i was accep
pted and the next thing
was i received papers and
everything to sail on the bendigo from
tilbury docks. I think 27th or 28th
of april nineteen twenty stephan.
We were two months at sea
or two months and two days i'm not too
sure. Again. But we did land in sydney
roughly towards the end of june. And where
did you get your first job. Well we were
we were sent as dreadnought boys we were
sent on to an agricultural sort. Not
a college actually but it
was an experimental farm
a government experimental farm and we will
all sent up to glen innes or rather our
batch was on the ship there were
other boys. I think i'm not
sure that they weren't doctor but now those
are something big brother movement or
something. I'm not too sure i do know that
we were sent to glen innes and what did
you do there. Well we had we were supposed
to learn how we learned about pigs and
sheep and cattle horses
plowing this kind of thing
but was that like well you with
a well i enjoyed it. The only thing was
we didn't get any pay. We got we got our
keep we had no money and they
weren't many jobs either
coming in. Farming. So i was
there i think nearly four months
and finally we three of us
ran away. To get neutral
not really. We ran away. We jumped the
train from from england in this. We walked
into the town. And jumped
a good train up over the border in those
days i'd want gallo which was the border.
They had to tranship the
the goods from one line
into another line because they were different
gauge railways. I don't know whether
they're saying now. But anyway. We got off
it. Well and gather. And started to walk
toward queensland and on the way we met
tramps or sundowners as they were in those
days. Why then the coming back. I said is
no good going there you'll get no work
there. So we turned back. And i one of us.
There was a job but while and gather on
a sheep station and we tossed up for it
and two of us lost the past this irish
fellow by the name of percy edgar he got
the job. So where did you go then. Then we
headed south jumping trains again till
we got to new castle because this
friend i was with had
a brother in newcastle working in the
coal mines and his proper of course took
him in you couldn't get him work but he
took him in the couldn't take me and that
left me alone. And i had
to go then hunting alone
and i wandered up the north
coast till i got to cooper nick
and i got a job there. On
a punt going across i think it was
the manning river taking traffic
to towards harrington and i used to
take this ponto over with an
ordinary you and you know on
a rope and i used to have to wind it across
and get to the other side of the river
with full heart or a load of cattle and
things like this in between times i did
a little milking for this man he
had a small small small holding
a small dairy farm and his
name was hinton by the way i
don't know where they are
now. Hum. I was in that job
until a man came across the pumped. With
a lorry load of bricks and cement and
sand and stuff and of course since i'd
already done bricklaying i
asked him for a job and i got
a job with him you had no inkling where
in england i had an england yes i had
and i gave my notice in there
and went to tarry where this
man lived his name was davies
dave davies long dead i imagine
because i was only
eighteen and he would be
a man perhaps forty over forty was here
and then from there he went to sydney and
from there i went to sydney. Yes. So we
caught up with you back there were down to
the harbour bridge again did you get any
other work before you were on the ridge.
Yes yes. The first job i
got in sydney was for
a man by name of neilson he had
a small box factory. I think
it was in elizabeth street
waterloo fire i can't quite remember. I
think it was elizabeth street waterloo. He
had
a box factory making boxes and
that was my first job in sydney.
And when you had finished up on the bridge.
Incidentally do you remember any any
incidents while you were working on the
approaches there that were the stand in
your mind when musing on whether
a tough incident. No not really no there
was only the one incident where the man
the man went up climbed on the steelworks
the reinforcing you know before it was
concreted and he just lost his nerve and
just couldn't get down wouldn't move
and it took all day to get him down.
How did they get into. Well they just
manhandled them down. I don't know i actually.
Why don't they had to give him drugs
or anything but they did get him down but
it was after five o'clock when they did
get him down as well as he was finished
up immediately. I would imagine. I don't
know what happened to him but he would be
a nervous wreck anyway. Who what when
you finished up after the several
months that you spent in the various parts
of the ash felting the what job did you
get after that. Um i the only jobs i
had after that i still did little
bits and pieces with this with these
two brothers of asphalt work.
I also got a job and i
think at the time it was
a wolf's building that they were building
in sydney around about the time i left as
a matter of fact i left that job to catch
the boat at circular quay to go back to
england. And. When you got back to it. We
were on the dole in australia at all. No
no. You see he went no when they first
there wasn't any dole when i first got to
sydney and it was only i think nineteen
twenty nine that they had to start
a form of rationing because not having
the old people out of work they were
starving and they open row of some circular
quay to dish out rations. First of
all two or three loaves of bread to purpose
and depending on family bit of butter
and meat and what have we. And then
of course they had to bring in
a scheme where they paid money. First of
all it was coupons. To give to you. Gross
and then it was money later but i never
applied for it being single. I somehow used
to manage to get
a little bit of work here and there you
know. And so avoided going for the door and
win. So you went back to england then and
did you have to pay your fare. I mean how
do you do for the mother sent my ticket.
So you managed to get back to england when
you've got back there. Did you manage to
get work. Oh yes yes i got work right away
and i never looked back. Really.
I was in london and quite
a lot before the war broke out intending
to come back to australia. I always
wanted to do that as soon as things improved.
However the war. I got married. First
of all and that put an end to it for the
time being but we did intend to immigrate
. And then of all progs out and
put paid to it. And can you make
a comparison of what things were like in
a stroller and what things were like in
england when you got back when i'm in only
thirty four. Oh yes and it was i.
I think i've already told you that
the trouble in europe was already
starting to you know
make itself felt and i
think the government was looking
to to sort of get factory is
going that they could use in
wartime. And they started
a lot of schemes in england i think they
starve them and about 1935. What they call
the shadow factory schemes and
in the north east. They built
they filled in
a big swamp drained it. And
build factories on that on that
land. Let them out. I think at a pound
a week or something very very cheap rent
so they can just tell them when they want
to die at
a minute's notice to get out. Which they
did issues war broke out. They put them
out and made them into munitions factories
that was the north east the team that
trading estate and they were lots of
those all over england but as i said in
1934 1935 they were starting to
prepare for the trouble in europe but
australia was much much worse than than
ever the oh yes they were simply because
australia didn't have
a lot by way of australian
manufactured goods and
well nobody would would invest money in
australia especially at that time at that
time you see the population was only
seven million people. And a million and
a half of them were in sydney and then
we don't mention lying or the their own
egging on the on the bondholders mr.
Jack lang you see he he he closed the banks
actually cut out well it was mr jack
lang. Well it wasn't it was the veteran
government that the bank shares but
the problem was there anyway. Can i ask
you something. Let's not get into the
philosophical end of it. Can you think of
anything else outstanding while you were
working around the bridge. No no
nothing outstanding it was just
a matter of survival just work as
much as i can get. Yes twelve hours
a day and very hot as well and dirty
as well. Hot and very dirty yes yes
yes i've seen some of the pictures of those
felting clouds you can't see them for
smoke. Yes yes they are very
very hot and dirty. Yes
you know i don't know how they go on
pollution in those days because it will
incredible i mean the smoke. Well i don't
think there was the pollution of this
today because they weren't the motor cars
about anyway it was more black smoke. Oh
yes. How
a small black smoke but
they were more horses to.
Demean what you did in the
spare time when you had
a little bit of money.
I used to go sometimes
a rush covers by stadium. I used to
a little bit of skating.
I used to do quite
a bit of surfing. Where did
you skate at rush covers bay.
I think that was where it was which
is an ice rink a roller rink. It was
a roller skating rink and the surfing. Oh
i used to go to the mall bond i could be
brought here you know and i was
there you know i went round and all
you see the cookie barn and these
places partly by which to swim in
botany bay before there were any of the oil
installations runny thing in those days
impotently bay. When we went there. We
could walk out all we could walk out.
Damn near a quarter of
a mile. You know and still just be waist
deep in water in the part of botany bay we
used as women to rember anything
else is to do it is pertinent. No
only mind around looking for
work and lying in the park at
and darlington darlington i think
it all. And the main park. Of
course hyde park there when you had
a bit of money. I mean when you're in work.
Well i used to do all i used to be at
the beaches every weekend we used to go
swimming. I used to love it. Swimming you
go to the theatre or the pictures. Oh yes
yes. I used to go. I was there when the
class of was opened which i think as
i remember it was round about 1933
that the plaza cinema was
open new brand new with
a picture silent or talk is there no they
were talking stand the talk is came in i
think iran about 1929 and the first
talkies we got in sydney who were world
full length talkies they were part of
our only half and half half silent half
talking. That was the first ones for the
first few months and then we have the full
length talking picture. To remember straight
in films being shown at that. Yes but
that now before the talkies
i remember there was
a film for the term of his natural
life. That one. I think i
saw that one in tari or or it might have
been open to the travelling film show
silent films show and we see go every
saturday night i used to ride in on horseback
into the town and the travelling day it
was in the school of arts and they had
these little benches that you sat on just
ordinary hard benches everybody sat on
and watched
a silent film that was before i went to
sydney. How much do they charge to remember
i think there that was
a sixpence. But in
sydney event i think was
a shilling ninepence or something
like that in sydney and i used to go
to the state theatre. I think it was the
prince harry's i'm not too sure. And of
course the plaza the old
tivoli was pulled down i
think around about the time that i arrived
in sydney from tower read the old
everleigh with the old music hall. Do
you remember the opening of the sydney
harbour bridge were you in sydney. Even
though yes i was i was there i was in the
crowds on the bridge and i watched the
incident. I could see the commotion
that was going on with captain the good
part of course i couldn't. Know binoculars
anything and i couldn't tell what the
hell was going on but i knew there was
a mind the press the press were very fast
quick on the street with the news where
it happened it was on the street at no
time. Remember that particularly i do. I
remember it very yes it's very vivid that
day the crowds and everything and i would
say i had probably not as many people as
there were on sunday but there were crowds
of people
a lot of people we were still working on
the bridge after it was open where you
know. No i finish working
before all it was opened that
there were
a few people still working on it. Afterwards
i understand. I think there must have
been the must have been maintenance men
would be on it all the time and possibly
they were painting it still i don't know.
And i don't know relying on us and other
information. No i don't think
there were many working on it.
Actually after it opened
other than maintenance and
maybe possibly putting up the the barriers
for the for the toll gates you know.
Yes well thank you very much mr. Evans.